ну і пан його ложками в миколаєві я зараз
але і ви знаєте що зали віденські компанії
справний магістра та спорт
тільки нападала ні коронавірус від
загиблого село шиття людей саме цьому
за раз про позицію і парламент заражаючи
партії волога звести народ мій шлях травня
шана і правда завтрашнього дня
100 нової не ціни на газ для населення
подати рекордними за всю історію та знову
я незалежної України тарифи за рукави
їм подавай транспорт його не буде складу
адже ти 9 до 14 тисяч гривень за тисячу
кубів
500 доларів за тисячу кубів зросла
зарплата дорослої пенсії вона ж
субсидіям їх. він танцював
ризики по вершині ж рівні ягоди не на
адже сьогодні порядку цим і ми або
чому змін бюджету і кому передач цієї
кішки нас більше не виплати субсидій
зловимо захищеним без там ми ссіли на
адже постанову так звані пристрасною
п'ятниці по перово тягає папери до
виду
будь-яким уживається в щоковій тобто в
черву стовпчиками офісами з
ще не знає і як піддаватися на 100
sweet 15 руку автоматично семи мільйонам
вдома господар буде тореро хова не
субсидій та людей приймали під потрібний
соціальне замовлення
ви ж за раз перед бачіли субсидій краще
для кращого рядка більше двох або ви
скажете вічка а 5 мільйонів українців
вдома господарство рахунок роберу б ти
врятуєш його всі уроку ви старше 17
уроків казала пильного і тариф на
електроенергію для населення
а як же ваші вбити янкі в 2 години тому
це і так само як її вбити н кіпр assist
з карти джейн і заїжджати andere рівні
дачі
чому ви так шви то про тебе забули
я поверну при каноні ще в серці травня ніби
компенсовано компенсовано 2-разове
зрощення актин на базовий продукт з по
бажанню українців індексації зарплат та
пенсій та села приводу нам треба за
відсотки на прем'єр-міністрів п'ятницю
щоб в ікона в цій нормі
закону пазах ес до України порядку чаю в
папку ризиків зростання then індексації
зарплати та пенсії сам цим у вашої анни
чудовий видосик моя сулія при свічці на
засіданні раді національні баскаки
оборону повз нього захищати україну та
українців
вам заражаємо о-го-го харчування з собою
бинти фікації ви замінили то лобізмом
лобізмом ваших тіла каналі та помилково
дитині
горілка чимось виявляється дуже важко парі
кладок українську мову
тут і реальні кими банер на рогівці
вдарив це українці явно думаю що за
разів законопроект 5554
отрута їм пріоритетом докази чекаючи України та
всі поважають a6 поставить і моя парада
поставте закон про колабораціонізм
вже пиріг у лежати верховній раді і на
наситили сунь інших санкцій анапе ставить
закону притягувати до давиду видами
отрута вколола ще 1 позицій я твердо хотел
б на волосся ще
мови треба називати своїми іменами ціни
на сни запит сили на саміт
панди ленський змінити ту намагайся but i
про суд не на те із забезпеченої
міжнародну коаліцію на 5 3 мг у
україни через україну через формування
ти їй політику нас робота в
чотирнадцятому роті цілісних тос
можливості
продовжити з анти про тепер особистого
потоку 2 відсипаємо за ленський фактично
на сьогоднішній день ми можемо ми миємо
ви знати 1000 потік два будуть обірвані
зв'яжи смак вашої випадкову
бездіяльністю україна парі твориться з
потрібної транзитної карини білорус 2
Новикова нас приваблює його прийнятий якщо
ви енергетичному стилі Москви і за
підвищення для Росії не but i союзниками
брюсселі crave в біг Росії то мовляв
первинний потік тому
на хто це мазохіст